[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt es
ist noch ziemlich früh am morgen man
sieht an den kleinen augen und heute
werde ich ein frühstück zubereiten
da fragen auch immer ganz viele nach den
rezepten deswegen zeige ich mich heute
wie ich unser traditionelles frühstück
zubereitet ich würde zwar traditionelles
türkisches rezept nennen weil es
wirklich viele rezepte aus der
türkischen kultur beinhaltet aber wir
mischen dann auch immer so ein bisschen
also dann gibt's dann auch guacamole
dazu und humus und alles mögliche was
wir sonntag morgens einfach gerne essen
im prinzip ist es nicht nur ein
frühstück sondern wirklich ein brunch
denn es gibt warme elemente es gibt
kalte elemente süß herzhaft und es wird
so verlängere ich mache mir kurz eine
liste was ich heute alles machen werde
und dann statt mir direkt so
chronologisch was bereit ich zuerst vor
was zuletzt damit am ende die warmen
sachen waren die alten sachen kalt und
das brot gebacken ist
[Musik]
lesetipp darauf warten alle was mache
ich was mache ich nicht explodiert bei
dem frühstück vor ok ich muss meine
prioritäten setzen
ja auf jeden fall wir fragen an
[Musik]
ich packe ja ganz gerne brot selber
heute mache ich ein schnelles fahren und
brot da gibt es das rezept auch schon
auf einem kanal
das geht wirklich schnell was aber auch
super schnell geht ist zum beispiel
magisches baguette da bereite ich den
teig auch gerne mal am abend vorher zu
und kann es dann kann ihn dann einfach
im kühlschrank aufgehen lassen abgedeckt
und am morgen einfach die brötchen
aufbacken jetzt wie gesagt die schnelle
pfannen brot dafür gebe ich jetzt
einfach alle zutaten in die
küchenmaschine der teig muss oder darf
gerne auch ein bisschen aufgehen muss er
aber nicht und dann kann ich hier in der
zwischenzeit alles andere vorbereiten
und ich habe jetzt hier nicht wie im
original rezept was ich euch verlinken
werde nur weiß mit benutzen sondern auch
einfach halb halten mit vollkornmehl
gemischt so hat man einfach direktor
christian dunkleres brot
[Musik]
während der mietzeit jetzt nicht töten
sondern am besten direkt alles weiter
vorbereiten was bei einem frühstück in
der türkei nicht fehlen darf sind
kartoffeln die werden halt frittiert und
morgens gibt es halt schon fest zum
frühstück aber ich muss echt sagen das
immer so eine coole gesunde und
ungesunde mischung aus allem
von daher darf man sich auch morgens mal
pommes können
die habe ich jetzt geschält die werden
kurz abgewaschen und dann schneidig sie
direkt
[Musik]
die kartoffeln über gieße ich jetzt mit
bisschen wasser damit sie nicht braun
werden und die welt einfach später
frittieren damit sie eben auch schön
warm sind wenn wir uns vom frühstück
setzen
der teig ist mittlerweile perfekt den
denke ich jetzt ab und kann den aufgehen
lassen damit bei mir aber schneller geht
nämlich jetzt die gerbstoffe im backofen
da muss er nämlich nur eine halbe stunde
auf gehen ansonsten einfach eine stunde
wenn man jetzt keinen dampf backofen hat
[Musik]
jetzt bereitet die eierspeise vor also
minimen da gibt es auch schon jetzt auf
meinem kanal ist es ein bisschen älter
ist noch aus der alten wohnung aber
trotzdem gut
das bereitet jetzt sofort dafür werde
ich nämlich zwiebel schälen und fein
schneiden
da diese kleinen grünen oder die langen
grünen-spitze paprika gibt meisten
türken die werden mit angebraten tomaten
kommen rein und ganz am ende kommt dann
das ei dazu und das ist auch echt super
lecker und das essen wir total gerne da
kann ich jetzt alle komponenten
vorbereiten einfach schon mal schneiden
so bereitet mir immer alles schön vor
und dann kommt man eigentlich auch nicht
in stress und ich nicht mehr zeit dazu
[Musik]
normalerweise gibt es beim türkischen
frühstück immer auch noch pech dazu das
ist wie langosch aber ich glaube das
mache ich heute nicht ich glaube dass
doch so heftig vielleicht mache ich nach
türkischen grenzfluss dazu also in eine
ausgewachsene stimme
wo ist meine gesangsstimme hin also in
ein ausgewachsenes brot so jetzt hab ich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nein
b
[Musik]
zwei finger
b
[Musik]
ich brauche mein braucht mein vater
bricht diese frau wenn man sie braucht
es geht wie joghurt kaufen und endlich
mit dieser schweren stunde allein den
sommer meine zuschauer
danke
okay das stumme jetzt schon da ich kann
keinen pc mehr machen die kartoffeln
habe ich das boot habe ich früher habe
ich ja bereits jetzt erst mal gemüse vor
und dann käse und wurst platte und die
aufstriche habe ich auch schon
also hier und da habe ich auch schon
jetzt gibt's viel gemüse also
traditionell immer gurken und tomaten
dann lege ich dazu noch oliven kleine
aprica meine frühstücksgäste sind schon
da mag es ihr helfen
so macht man das man bereitet so lange
vor bis der gast mithelfen muss das ist
so die tradition tradition
ich habe kein karohemd können überleben
ist okay ich kümmere mich später darum
nein das nomis neko paprika ist alles
okay kannst du hier draußen aus stimmt
das tor eingeschlichen
jetzt ist eingeschlichen
[Musik]
als ich hier noch die snack paprika
drauf was habe ich schon aufgesetzt t
mache ich gleich schneiden
die lügen wir so drauf und dann zeige
ich jetzt was ich glaube das kennst du
nicht noch nicht
also jetzt gibt's noch dahin pigments
dahin ist sesampaste und pack mers das
ist so eine melasse aus trauben und das
wird dann gemischt und dann gibt es das
so als tipp dazu so als brot steckte
aber nicht auf und das macht man weil es
auch super nahrhaft ist und dann gibt
mir das noch einmal kindern die
vielleicht so wissen zu wenig essen das
er einfach ein bisschen speck kriegen
aber es ist auch appetit anregend und
hat mir auch gedacht dankeschön und dann
einfach treiben lassen und das steht
zwar trauben sirup drauf aber es ist
kein serum ist es besser dass der rest
was übrig bleibt wenn der zucker
irgendwie aus den trauben entzogen wird
als ihre werkstatt besser wenn man
höchstwahrscheinlich marktstudien aber
die meisten denken weil sirup direkt an
zucker und so weiter und eigentlich ist
es das nicht
kein zucker das hatte ich so aus den
trauben heraus nichts du das machen sie
klar sesampaste die ist halt immer nie
so ganz homogen keine emulgatoren drin
sind und dann setzt sich immer das fett
ab dann natürlich schon mal laden
denn das auge isst ja mit
alles fertig ist hab ich mal das machst
du jeden morgen nur sonntags durch
antakya willkommen sonntag noch mal
wieder sind zwei testtage gibt es auch
mehr lohne
es ist eigentlich gibt es beim
türkischen frachter echt immer viel obst
und gemüse sehr gesund ja wenn man sich
dann mal so die kartoffeln anguckt gar
nicht noch frittiert sie gibt achso acht
denkt ausgewirkt hat das hier ist die 18
ich wollte mich montiert werden also mit
unserem brötchen und käse kommen und
dann okay gut bei uns gibt es ja man
kann ja so von allem etwas durch und das
gute klima ist nicht jeden tag macht es
doch viel zeit hat dafür dass jeden tag
zum arzt aber auch gut dann gesagt nein
hin zu jam oder so ich würde schon von
weitem kommen verspricht ihren tank ist
schon gut so ich hab das jetzt gemacht
wo wir hier weiterhin alles aus dem
chinesen raus zu klopfen
ich weiß nicht wieso außerdem soll ich
lernen gelernt
es sollte schon schön angenehm
appetitlich flüssig so rutschte es
fertig urteil selber sehen wir sehen
gleich fertig war früher das tut mir
leid was ich habe ich damit gerechnet
dass so wie immer zu spät
da helfen keine finden greifen muss um
halb 10 10 und dann was halt so hass und
gibt es brot das ist so krass pünktlich
um halb zehn
natürlich sie nur 30 job ja dass ich
glaube das hat eher den gegenteiligen
effekt für mich ist dieses fenster legen
aber ich bin ja das ist den
gegenteiligen effekt hatte wir lassen
komm schon einen job hat es bis jetzt
keinen einzigen job
okay das ist auf fettes da gebe ich noch
früchte drauf
[Musik]
ich habe nur hier schon humus und
guacamole gemacht so kamen bohle gehört
dazu
nee das mach ich gegessen zufolge plant
das ist
[Musik]
da kann ich glaube jetzt ok danke jetzt
türkischen dichter wie man denn drauf
einfach ins waschbecken braucht manchmal
gleich weg den mag skurril winter die
entwicklung ja ich mag generell also
eure euro/t sein dass hier die ganze
zeit finde das sehr gut und er wird
einmal ausgewaschen
nach dem auswaschen dann aufbrühen mit
heißem wasser und dann einfach ziehen
lassen
so etwa 15 minuten da hat man hier oben
das t konzentrat drin und hier unten das
kochende wasser und dann kann man immer
bestimmen wie stark der tee sein soll
und außerdem bleibt der tee schön warm
und wird nicht bitter weil nicht dass
hier gekocht wird sondern das wasser da
unten
deswegen macht man das so gut cook
geholfen
super das ist es auch danach wuchs sehr
gut nach links stellt dann haben wir das
auch fertig hier ist das ist auch fertig
darüber stand ja oh ja und leben
die kannst du auch noch anrichten hast
du diese hereingelegt in olivenöl in
orangenschale knoblauch und rosmarin
start in den tag richtig ist startbereit
okay jetzt kann man schon mal die
kartoffeln frittieren und das management
also das rührei machen
ich nehme ganz kurz das verstehe ich du
nimmst jetzt auch das ganze
wahrscheinlich schon bislang her schon
bislang schon schon da rein so wie das
erste öl dort erhitzen wir erst das öl
und ja das recht wir müssen es nicht
übertreibt
und dann werden die einfach
abtransportiert so wie man das halt
jeden morgen macht bot sich ja und ich
kann jetzt hier die zwiebeln anbraten
mit den spitz fabbrica die sind nicht
scharf ist eigenschaft sehr gerne ja
okay da man mit chilli drauf jetzt
müssen sie alle leiden
jetzt müssen sie alle leiden
[Musik]
ja geht schon findet er jetzt einen
finger länger halten
dann hätte ich wirklich mir sorgen
gemacht lange sind sie schon alle
wir gucken habe ich glaube ein halbe
halbe halbe halbe nochmal und deckel
drauf und dann oh dann kann man noch
einen käse dick machen das ist so der
lieblings tipp von samira und den leben
auch die zuschauer die wollte immer
wissen wie das funktioniert jetzt darfst
du denn gleich machen
ich habe kurz den käse das mache ich
natürlich geschwind sehr einfach
als ich hier ist jetzt ein päckchen
sahne darüber dass gramm unternehmen
jetzt ein rädchen käse so das sind
verschiedene medien ja aber okay
denn unser kleiner hast du jetzt einfach
immer zu klein sei rein ja voll kriegen
ja das ist weichkäse wir liegen denn so
genau so manche haben wir frühstücken
doch jetzt ja sage zu langsam war
die später vielleicht auch wenn klopp
startet du bleibst bei uns ein frühstück
geht's gut
und dann wird das hier jetzt komme ich
so an die grenzen seiner möglichkeiten
hier gebe ich jetzt noch die paprika
dazu
sie ist einfach auch mit geschmack ich
glaube wir wandern hier rüber mit dem
käse teppich bewundern gerade einfach
nur ich stehe hier sehr nicht hallo ich
bin auch ein zuschauer so und dann hole
ich den schneebesen und danach zu den
käse rühren und der schmilzt jetzt hier
drin so klicken
das würde noch nicht das ganze geheimnis
verriet sein oder nein nein da kommt da
noch mehr dazu zum binden
ich ruhe das hier so lange bis ist schön
natürlich nicht so locker aus
dies sind alles mit
dann nehme ich hier noch im turm käse
dem musste auch probieren da ist der
wahnsinn so ein ganz traditioneller käse
so wird sich durch die vielen servern
anja herzog ein stück ich schon fast ein
bisschen parmesan ein bisschen hartkäse
mäßig der bot im fass gereift und
deswegen ist er so ganz besonders
aromatisch und weil du chili marx geben
noch ziemlich drauf ich habe ich mir das
eingebrockt
[Musik]
das ist gleich dann löst sich alles
fensterbild management das ist lecker
ich merke dass man wenn wir mit dem
krieg löst wenn wir beide erstmals so
richtig lecker so richtig mittagsschlaf
mittagsschlaf ja das wird auf jeden fall
mittagsschlaf frühstück das ist was da
ist wird es fit und dann legt sich noch
mal hin so etwas honig kommt bei mir
muss auch etwas butter bei de gerne auch
mal ja aber nur für marmelade und nicht
dazu oder marmelade kino.to jetzt sind
wir die schälchen aus ok also ich hätte
bei mir in der küche fünf schüsseln
ich glaube wenn wir schon lange drüber
da sehen wir da sind
[Musik]
mach's mit einem anderen warum diese
wanderer ein
ich glaube weil er einst härter ist als
die anderer träger dafür wird im auge
weil das haus 6 es stimmt es geht immer
des kapitals in der rechten hand ja
wahrscheinlich werde ich das drauf
schlage ich glaube gemacht ist immer mit
der mitte war nicht okay warte ich
mach's nicht bewusst ich probier es noch
mal gespannt
das ja hier schlägt das immer mit der
sie ist er immer dann stimmt das was ich
drauf schlage geht kaputt
jetzt aber mal tatsächlich mal ganz
interessant da mal rausfinden warum
sagen oder nicht genannt werden oder
erwartet dann versuche ich mal also wenn
man sie für mich zu berühren muss wenn
man das eine draufschlägt ist was man
schlägt der skizze beleben und die
weisheiten her so dass dann irgendwann
[Musik]
also ist der käse gibt den alle so leben
käse und sahne gekocht stecke jetzt
aufgelöst und dann bindet man das ganze
einfach mit mehr
das heißt kurs abkam ist ein rezept vor
meiner freundinnen des checkers cab
deutsch sondern bestimmte regierungen
sohn hat bestimmt mit gruppe und das ist
ein ganz traditionelles rezept zum war
käse das kino bei denen der region
sunny oder wenn das von 250 megabyte
okay die paprika habe ich leicht
anbrennen lassen aber das macht sechs
toren bester roman wie kommen die
tomaten dazu werden mit geschmort bis
sie weich sind
dann haben wir das auch und ich sollte
so langsam konsistenz ist perfekt ok bis
zur hälfte
ja
den teig zu überholen wie sie es gerne
perfekt die sind jetzt auch fertig
schwierig sein vermute bereiten am
morgen oder wenn man aber noch so ein
ziel hat ja also ich mach das halbinsel
privat zu machen so manchmal man paris
dazu und dann las ich musik laufen und
dann geht eigentlich ja also ich glaube
ich meditiere so vor mich hin morgens
wenn wir noch mittlerweile machen
schnittlauch dann habe ich am abend so
schön geschnitten kapiert dann habt ihr
nicht live erlebt war so die eine
schubkarre voll schnittlauch randständig
gespielt er war leider zu spät dann
werde ich natürlich mitgeschnitten
braucht natürlich jetzt bin ich gespannt
wird jetzt im mittelstand noch mal die
schön gleich groß
und dann mit zwei rollen räte haben
jetzt immer so ein teilnehmer möchte ich
noch mit weiß ich nicht ob das gute
spencer von außen an lehrlingen im
pflaster habe ich eigentlich ein
bisschen sorge ja ich guck dir zu ich
kommentiere das mit frechen kommentaren
echt das nennst du in wallgau
das ist die technik ja das ist die
technik nicht kannst auch einhändig hier
von außen nach innen also wenn ich damit
anfangen bist du fertig und dann wirst
du meinen korrigieren das kann hier
schon so und das wären dann brötchen und
das werden sie flache pfanne brot fallen
drohte ja geil
das ist schon das ist cool sowie nahen
brot nur ein bisschen fluffigen ja ja
das ein bisschen wenn wir solche spieler
wird und dann so nach wo ist das brot
darum gehen wird
der tabelle immer noch einmal kommt
sowieso rück gehörten ja stimmt das kann
man abschreiben an der seite natürlich
aber gut sonst da hätte ich glaube ich
werde nichts aufgekommen jetzt doch
angenehm gewesen wäre ein klassischer
bradleys gebrauchsanweisungen gewesen
das kann man so rolf kuhl glauben wir
die dinger drin
die sind nur deko damit man immer die
gleiche größe dem abstand kann ja
verstehen
ich glaube ich mache tatsächlich dünne
[Musik]
und die kommen dann auf ein blech leihen
oder die packen wir gleich in der pfanne
pfanne ja können wir vorne button ja man
so durch aber auch kreativ mit deinen
back wegen sowie namen brot mit ihrem
doch immer diese dem sonst irgendwas
sagen tunnel aber das war jetzt auch
weil ich das ja immer dieses loch drin
ist und dann packen wir es eigentlich
nicht so gern
jetzt können wir machen also das kann
ich dir bauen jetzt wollte nur cool sein
aber das können wir aus meinen die
stelle wo ich gesagt habe ich kann das
machen wir doch so gern dass du kannst
ein stück bauen
na ja da gibt es ein richtig gutes
türkisches hauptgericht das nennt sich t
stick safestick käfer typ piper cherokee
ich kann mir gut vorstellen das ist
nicht 100 prozent das ist in so einem
tontopf und sie hat eben die erde in
seinen feuer lauf gelassen und dann darf
es da halt waren so einige stunden und
dann machst du diesen tontopf außenrum
kaputt und perfekt ist richtig richtig
den herrn
aber dafür brauchen sie ein foto auf dem
man zerschlagen haben ja vor allem so
bequem irgendwelchen aus mit vielleicht
klar sagen das ist dass ich ganz geil
finden würde wieder so ein eigener pc
oder ein stein holz kohle heute ging
einfach mal schnell das thema noch
stunde schnell zusammen gebaut oder das
bauen
ich kann es probieren
aber das ist dann immer mit der mit der
prämisse wenn ich das hier bauen ist es
immer mit der prämisse ist gehört auch
dir
es ist mit comedy gemacht wurden ok
coleman ist soweit ist dass mir zu heiß
noch mal das zu heiß ich nehme die
mannschaft nämlich mal an lehrern der
betrieblichen denen die mal kurz aus dem
bild die kartoffel
und mach uns hier platz also eigentlich
geht es mit den kartoffeln echt
schneller aber die kartoffeln die waren
seltsam
die wollten die wollen nicht gut
jetzt habt ihr hier diese masse die wir
jetzt gewürzt zum fest die kartoffeln
die wollen im mittel kommt dann oregano
werkbund rausch über das dann gemerkt
dass berg wurden geraubt nicht
verkleinert ist so ein bisschen mit der
hand schwer
deswegen nennt man sie auch im fachkreis
den moerser natürlich ne es immer hier
salz und pfeffer bevor das war noch
einmal durch die hände gehört wird
durchgehend beschäftigt
ich danke gott
das video stamme sei wieder da sieht man
mal wieder der mutter vom neckar
hauptthema der rapper wird
ich bin der moerser vom neckar an
vorsicht heiß na gut das nicht sehr sehr
heiß
da war guter geschmack ist sehr lecker
ja 100% 100 sehr lecker und jetzt fühle
ich die hier rein das ist jetzt so
optisch mehr
also ich jetzt auch darin garen können
aber die sind mir zu klein jetzt für
zwei portionen es gebe ich das hier ein
dass hier mit dem brot so mit dem halb
flüssigen 1
ich mag die sprache die hier gesprochen
wird auf essen muss aber ganz kurz
warten damit wir hier staates brot
backen können und dann haben wir gleich
und dann nur noch super und 1 und eis
zurück in münchen beraten dazu fertig
gerichts nachhinein aber irgendwo auf
der arbeitsplatte nicht eine schüssel
seinem auf der arbeitsplatte
hier riecht's nach ich sag's euch aber
ganz ehrlich bei so zwölf eiern
vorstellen das ist tatsächlich
irgendwann als ich glaube ich mach das
mal wenn du bei mir vorbeikommt da würde
ich einfach mal irgendwo so ein bisschen
ein verteilen im büro und damit ich mal
gucken ob sie auslöst oder bis alles nur
eine große show ist und mithin büro
sehr schön ist aber ganz gut oder machst
du das auch ein schlüssel oder so wenn
man mal verliert man mal kurz noch mal
so richtig tippen ja und dann rutscht an
da aber auch oft das problem ist wenn du
etwas mitgemacht hast sondern so
gewaschen hafen gestellt das klingt echt
wird es am 8
aber macht das wett
wenn die katze luft reizt geht ist und
stinkt noch schlimmer deswegen dass
immer die fenster zu man merke heute mal
können wir einblenden kriemann overland
cellestis niemals kalte luft auf eiger
buch dann wird es mehr
aber ich freue mich richtig wenn das
irgendwo drin steht und weil ihr die
farbe eingearbeitet ist wirklich so
wende zum beispiel google macht mit
baiser ja mit obendrauf und du stellst
den raus zum kühl das stimmt denn dieser
veräppelt er weg es ist so gut nächste
mal wenn ich vorbeikomme machen wir
machen wir mal gesehen und macht man mal
den großen tag
wenn man so gesehen stückchen ist echte
so ok das packen wir mal die drohte die
sind ohne da ist mike tyson halten
der kleine ohne irgendwas dabei
und dann ist es fertig ist schon das
scheint wohl die kids machen davon gern
mit morgens die rollen dann aber aus
glaube das ist eine gute beschäftigung
haben sie schon mal was erlebt am morgen
ist to cancel entfernt
damit machte sich nickel 1
laut spiegel als spiegelei hatte ich
noch nicht ich habe sich nur immer mal
so in so einer eingeschnitten dann aber
auch nur eine kleine sehr lecker ablauf
bibel oder schnittlauch schnitten
richter gewannen die hölle
sommer zu lassen damit eignet sie
übertönen jetzt den geruch mitte wo die
kleinen bildchen von 10 1 megapixel
machen kann was von anrichten und dann
echt schön
während im gleichen schritt ja und
hätten schritt mit waffen einfach durch
eine pfanne mehr einfach hier drin und
basieren
so reicht es für uns zwei dann zum
frühstück oder wahlweise wird noch mit
klage
ich glaube also ich weiß nicht wann er
ist ein sehr reichliche am morgen ist ja
aber wir arbeiten hier gerne von von
humus zu bagamoyo ich mal hier es ist
schon so dass videos frühstück von a bis
z die massen immer sachen die die
absolut zu haben banane wie ferien
zah heftiges oder gibts ja wieder
steigen
[Musik]
sie gibt nochmal die gegner geschlagen
ja ist schon ein box können
ich glaube ich mache das jetzt so und
dann macht das ein rein denn das sieht
schön aus wenn die substanz so da oben
drauf legen
[Musik]
und 2 abstriche muss was frau bestreite
ich raus
das war's
[Musik]
massa kommt keiner rein aber bei dem
kommt der gipfel von dem song text
vergessen
wie kommen wir nicht an
[Musik]
hierbei management noch ein bisschen
salz und pfeffer und dann dürft ihr so
ganz leicht verrühren und da darf das
aber gleich schon ein bisschen noch
weich sein somit den wir es gerne
es zieht auch gleich ein bisschen nach
[Musik]
sturm kommt ach das turnier ist zu
besuch und ich habe mir gedacht komm
bauen wir ein kleines frühstück auf
eigentlich habe ich mir gedacht so schön
für das kleine sonnenwetter und stadt
sonnenwetter haben weiß leiter
baustellen geräusche regenwetter was
schon jetzt gewiss aussuchen wo wir
hinwollen gar um ein kart wii chimären
mondbär wir fliegen zum mond das muss
man machen schnipsen oder oder nach
venedig ich war noch nie in venedig oder
auf der bosporus brücke in istanbul
der vogel
so wollen wir noch hin irgendwann können
wir neben einem seriösen frisst er uns
nicht alles was ich finde ich glaube ich
sehr stöße zu bleiben und auch in paris
[Musik]
mo
schnell wieder weg
in frankfurt werde schon noch frankfurt
wird in baku wo stehst davor dann ist so
commerzbank-zentrale berliner mauer
berliner mauer ich glaube auch in seine
küche aber nur ganz kurz wohl leider
wenig aufgeräumt ok weiter gehts wieder
in deine küche ok dann essen wir noch
gar kein thema das macht man doch einem
attentat sache eigentlich nimmt man
immer so schön so und dann probierst du
dich so durch also so der mobility city
hat den muss ich sag mal probieren der
slider kalt denn wir sind zu viel
gereist
das wird richtig gut schmecken glaube
ich
könnte man in das wir als management
könnte man da auch noch so klein machen
definitiv das glück hat lebt männer mit
flotter job zu job ganz klar also das
echt so als wir früher mit meinen eltern
in der türkei waren bei unserer familie
da gab es dann alles so am boden aber
mit so einer acht meter langen
tischdecke denn alles wird am boden
ausgelegt und nimmst du dir die
tischdecke auf dem schoß weil du sitzt
er am boden knien und da ist die strecke
praktisch eine serviette zum schutz und
dann ist man so am boden also auf
tischdecken machen wir doch das war's
waghäusel machen doch wieder war heute
da hielt aber auch schön ja ist schon
schön oder also ließ ganz gut doch alles
so frisch und wir können uns holen ja
ich hab auch probleme ja das sind das
interessiert mich zu sehen weil du hast
gesagt das sind auf aufschnitt aufstrich
aufstrich der grund ist ja sie ist ein
passt und trauben melasse
das ist gesund aber sehr nahrhaft also
das hat schon viele kalorien aber gute
kalorien
gute frage irgendwann von herz oder man
kommt der mittelwert reisen
das denkt man es gerne kinder geil oder
stillenden frauen noch die milch gut
wird lecker so fragte milchpaket über
die schulter geworfen und dann ist mir
alles so durcheinander
jetzt zu mir gefallen probiert den turm
auch damit schluss gemacht mit chili und
wie man zugreifen
[Gelächter]
und da nicht so aufdringlich also der
der schmeckt traditionell in der türkei
schmeckt sehr starken weiler in so viel
gemacht wird ob ich hier wird einfach in
fässern gereift
deswegen schmeckt da wird sich aber
nicht so dominant und weißt du von ihm
das kommt es kommt von mir jemanden der
nicht gerne käse ist ja ich nehme ich
auch ich also eigentlich so milden käse
mag ich aber so stinken käse mag ich
nicht hier
vielen dank fürs frühstück der absolute
oberhammer jeden tag du wird es wirklich
nicht durchgehen
wie das aussieht will nicht dass er geht
ich will nicht dass er geht deswegen
habe ich die mutter frühstück
aufgetischt ich hab's mit kuchen und
torten es versucht ich habe es mit pizza
versucht ich habe es mit allem versucht
dabei ergeht trotzdem ich komme aber
wieder herr staeck sturm ii muss bleiben
petition online
wir machen eine online-petition stock
ziehen und schreibt sturm muss bleiben
so also das war unser kleines frühstück
morgen tagt szene deutschland aber sehr
lecker okay zugegeben das gibt es nicht
jeden tag es gibt echt so sonntags unter
der woche essen wir echte müsli porridge
gesunde sachen smoothies und sowas gibt
es dann ganz ausführlich in reichlicher
wochenende das sitzt man dann zusammen
so drei stunden und ist und schmeckt und
die rezepte gibt's natürlich online auf
sase blog de oder in der app und ich
freue mich jetzt auf eure frühstücks
bilder auf ihr frühstücks buffet mito
tct mal verreisen zum abschluss
[Gelächter]
da war ich noch nie
[Musik]
tschechien das niveau wird naja auf dem
berg auf dem berg auf und wir sitzen im
vergleich schon wieder berggruen
es ist kein kronen knapp vorne wächst ja
da kommt das mitlaufen herunter wir
kommen jetzt noch hier so schön
wanderweg und ein mal am nordpol war
einmal nordpol okay und jetzt gutes kalt
mag ich nicht immer am südpol musik wohl
das gleiche ich kam wird schon jetzt am
strand tot
sonnencreme für mich ich hätte ein brot
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
wollte jetzt eigentlich auch dazu
bestimmt wir alles alleine essen wie das
für die letzte nachricht für die anderen
hammer kommt dem frühstück
[Musik]